You don't like watching yourself
if you're in a dramatic role?
But I love watching myself do comedy.
(laughs and cheers)
I don't know.
Comedy, you're innately making fun of yourself.
It's very liberating.
The more ridiculous you look, the more successful you are.
But in a serious role...
Nobody likes to see himself or herself up on screen.
You all remember the first time you ever saw yourself.
You completely freak out.
No actor completely overcomes that.
The more serious you are, the more embarrassed.
So I avoid myself when I'm serious.
But I secretly watch 3rd Rock from the Sun reruns.
(cheers)
Life, life!
What about you, Mel?
Do you like to watch yourself on screen?
It does make you kind of wriggly.
I get pretty wriggly.
I try not to do it.
Other people give me reviews
and that does me in completely.
What about when you're watching a Mad Max movie
or something from a long time ago?
Does it bring you back to that time when you see it?
No, it doesn't.
I just feel the arthritis and the hemorrhoids.
(laughs)
And I hearken back to a time when those things didn't exist.
And it was visibly apparent.